Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
I have made a mistake in my documentary on the history of England.
I portrayed this corpse as a victim of pagan human sacrifice in Ireland.
However,
this was an error.
This is actually the toll and man from Denmark.
Thank you to all of you in the comments section who corrected me because I
missed that.
So in this video I thought I had honor this poor fellow and correct my mistake
by doing my research and telling the tale of the toll on man.
So to begin,
while scientists don't know a whole lot about who the Toa men was,
they do know a lot of strangely specific details regarding the corpse.
Most of the,
because of its excellent preservation,
the tone man was discovered in Jutland Denmark in 1950 by farmers.
It was preserved so well in fact that the woman who discovered the corpse
thought she had discovered the body of a recent murder victim and they alerted
the police.
The police is well examine the corpse as if it were a murder victim.
But it was such a strange case that they called in the archeologist Patriot
Ville home glob to examine it.
Glob was the first to determine that the corpse was over 2000 years old.
Scientists are not entirely sure when the man died,
but it was most likely between 400 and 200 BC.
They are however sure of how he died.
He was hanged most likely as a part of a ritual sacrifice because of the
arrangement of his body.
He was likely around the age of 40 at the time of his death,
he was mostly naked except for a cap made of animal skins.
Examination showed that he likely did not shave for around 24 hours before his
death and his final meal was 12 to 24 hours before his death consisting of a
kind of porridge for the more this choice of foods suggest he died in the winter
or the early spring.
His organs were left wonderfully preserved as well.
And in 1976 the Danish police made a fingerprint analysis of the corpse,
thus making it telimans fingerprints,
one of the oldest on record,
the corpse measured at five foot three inches.
Though people were shorter in those days,
it was likely that the Pete in which the corpse was preserved caused it to
shrink the low oxygen,
high acidity environment of the Pete along with a very cold climate of the
Nordic countries is what allowed the corpse to be so well preserved.
Such a corpse is known as a bog body.
The oldest bog body discovered was the Kohlberg man dating back to around 8,000
BC.
Also from Denmark.
Many other bog bodies have been discovered and other parts of the world,
and many of these bodies were also the victims of what seems to be ritual
sacrifice including 500 such bodies from Denmark alone and many from the British
isles.
The condition of the tone man was so similar to those of the corpse is found in
the British isles that it led to my mistake today.
The tone man is displayed in his silk,
a Borg Museum in Denmark,
though unfortunately only the head is original.
In the 1950s there was a lack of technology needed to preserve an entire body,
and thus only the head was able to be saved.
Unfortunately,
the body withered away over the decades.
For more videos like this and videos on many other subjects be should have take
out fire of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.